tuesday edition pft
ot the place where we talk about the
things we weren't able to get to during
the two hours on
nbcs end which will soon be the two
hours live on peacock with the rear on
nbcsn and we're looking forward to that
chris sims mike florio here with you and
chris the washington franchise
the washington football team officially
now known as continues to stay in the
news for reasons on the field and off
the field let's start with the
off the field reason or wait are we on
the field we're starting with the on the
field okay
on the field they only told me five
times before we started today
on the field there's a question about
the quarterback position
and look for now alex smith still not
off the physically unable to perform
list
still not able to go out and practice
and prepare but you know what no one
else is either they'll put the pads on
until the middle of the month
if alex smith is healthy he's in the mix
ron rivera the head coach of the team
said that yesterday dwayne haskins
second year quarterback 15th overall
pick in 2019
says that he welcomes the ability to
compete with alex smith and frankly
chris my reaction is
i wouldn't if i were dwayne haskins
because
in this environment with limited time to
get ready
and the extensive experience that alex
smith has
dating back to 2011 when he had to do
something like this with the 49ers with
a new head coach and they almost made it
to the super bowl that year
2006 he ran the offense
the same offense that scott turner is
running in washington when norv turner
was the offensive coordinator of the
49ers
if alex smith is healthy if he's still
the guy
physically that he was before that
horrible broken leg and the infection
that almost took his leg and his life
he's winning that competition in this
environment
next year full off season different
story
but i wouldn't want to compete with alex
smith with limited opportunities
limited reps and a lot of work to do in
a short period of time
because smith has been there and done
that chris well mike i'm not going to
argue with
anything you said there i mean you're
right you know but but the big
question to me and you're right it all i
mean alex smith is a pro he's been
around a long time
you know he's a really smart guy we do
know that
you know and of course can can can help
a team win football games you know he's
a little bit of a game manager as
we've always said he is a guy that's you
know not going to win you games but not
going to lose you games either
i don't know if i necessarily love that
you know to to me though
you know one realistically i don't
expect them to be ready
to play week one i i don't you know
we'll see i hope so that would be great
it'd be a great story everything
involved in it but i think we're
probably still a little ways off there
now you talk about yeah he's experienced
he knows offense is better he's
certainly going to be
you know more ready to play with less
reps than a guy like dwayne haskins
who's still raw and as we talked about
he's only played one year of college
football
but to me there's got to be a line there
right to where if you're going to make a
decision the washington red
the washington team damn i'm sorry the
washington team where you got to
you got to figure out what is it worth
how work
how much is it worth to put alex smith
out there you know how good alex smith
is you know what he is
dwayne haskins you're not really sure
yet and
just as it looks right now i would say
his potential
or his ceiling is greater that then of
what alex smith's can be
so you know at what point how much does
alex smith have to
beat out dwayne haskins it would that
would be in my mind if i'm ron rivera
because you're trying to set something
up here for the future
you know you got yeah you got dwayne
haskins terry mcclure and some other
guys
you're trying to build something you
know with alex smith
the very real possibility you're back
into the quarterback conversation
you know a year or two down the road now
if you start to go with him as the
starter so
you know i i would think it would have
to take what i'm basically saying
is alex smith to blow a dwayne haskins
out of the water
during training camp and the preparation
before the preseason game
because dwayne haskins is a top 20 pick
and they know what alex smith is
and there is something to be excited
about with the future of dwayne haskins
at least that would be my thought i
don't know you agree
but but chris oh aaron rodgers sat for
three years on the bench in green bay
yeah right
um so yeah you look at the problem is
this
haskins already has had a chance to play
it's so
hard to put that toothpaste back in the
tube
once you've made the investment in a top
of the first round
quarterback once he's playing
anything other than him continuing to
play
is viewed as a demotion definitely
because it is yep
and it potentially screws him up right
it's the kind
like remember how elway got jerked
around by dan reeves at one point like
the way you the way you handle your
quarterback
it sends messages to the team it sends
messages to the quarterback and it
starts to get him possibly seeing ghosts
possibly gripping the ball a little bit
too tight because he's afraid to make a
mistake
all those things that can that can just
derail a guy's career
that's the risk of not going with dwayne
haskins it is
it definitely is and in my heart of
hearts here and again i don't know
i you know i haven't talked to anybody
down in washington that's given me an
update about where things are or
anything like that
but i i think the the other thing that's
going on here to me
and this has been a theme since ron
rivera has taken over
you know i think he's trying to make
sure that dwayne haskins is on edge
you know i think he probably likes alex
smith might be competing with you here
you know
because hey we heard the stories about
dwayne haskins he is young
he is learning what life is like in the
nfl you know so yeah
kyle allen's there but then you hear
whoa alex smith might be coming into the
room and practicing and competing can be
you know
that's going to get a guy even more you
know crossing the t's dot in the eyes
whoa i better get on my game here comes
a guy that's
been to some pro bowls and played in
some nfl playoff games you know
i think there's probably a little bit of
that as far as just another way to
motivate the guy
too to to see some growth as
a player yeah i mean look i agree with
you and it's not going to be an easy
decision if alex smith is healthy but
ron rivera wants to turn that team
around
they want to win football games and
somebody's going to have to decide
what gives the team the best chance to
win this year and it very well may be
setting aside taking a step back i mean
you know the attitude would be hey
if dwayne haskins can't handle taking a
seat
for a guy who is accomplished who is
effective and who is more prepared right
now
to take this team where it needs to be
if he can't handle that when he gets a
chance to play next year
then he isn't he's not the guy for the
job that's right he's not he's not so
you know it's
it's a very simple litmus test if you
can't handle this
when we explain to you why we're doing
it when when you understand that alex
smith is one of the
you know sneaky better quarterbacks in
the past 15 years
he doesn't get the credit he deserves
and he's healthy
and it's a great story and he's in a
position to get this team ready under
these crazy ass circumstances
if you can't handle that then yeah you
can't handle being an nfl quarterback
week in and week out because it's going
to be adversity
of all sorts of shapes and sizes every
week of your career
that you you know spot on i mean i get
so
that to me is one of those like token
phrases sometimes i hear people talk
about where oh
you know you can't bench that young
rookie quarterback or that second year
you'll ruin him no to your point you're
spot on
if it ruins him then he's ruined he's
done he can't play in the nfl he's
obviously too fragile
and can't get back up off the canvas
after getting knocked down and continue
to fight
so i do think that's a very real
possibility there's no doubt you know
the other thing i'll say just to wrap up
my thought on it too
is this is an offense that we talked
about you know i believe yesterday
the lack of weapons you know with darius
geiss gone now
you know to me that's where haskins
certainly gives them a
an advantage over a guy like alex smith
too alex smith is not a guy that's
looking to take aggressive
shots down the field i don't know if his
skill set really
meshes with a guy like terry mclaurin
who's kind of like a tyree kill
speed burner like i'm gone that fits
with dwayne haskins and they have
something there from back of their days
at ohio state
so i would think from that aspect too he
might be more exciting or be able to
more
create more buzz and big plays
than a guy like alex smith and actually
fit within what they want to do
offensively maybe more so
it'll be interesting we'll see we got a
long way to go to see if al smith is
ready to go but
uh yeah they're gonna have some things
to think about in washington
daniel snyder is ready to go when it
comes to litigation and he's filed suit
in the past and last week he started a
process aimed at getting to the root
of some of the craziest of the rumors
that came out in the days before the
washington post article
identifying 15 former employees who
believe they were the victims of sexual
harassment while working for the team
now chris
do not i'm this is your lawyer and your
broadcast partner speaking to you do not
mention any of the crazy rumors that
were out there
because it can get us into trouble thank
you council there were
there there were reports reports or
rumors or whatever that made their way
onto some platforms
daniel snyder taking legal action and
here's where it gets interesting in a
filing from monday
snyder suggested there's a former
employee
who and again these are the allegations
this is what snyder's trying to explore
and get to the bottom of
a former employee who he believes was
getting some sort of compensation to say
bad things about him to fabricate bad
things about him
and he's trying to get to the bottom of
the rabbit hole to find out
who's behind it and i've read the
article
on espn.com the article in the new york
times i haven't seen the article
in full in the washington post yet but i
sense there's a lot of hinting
that's being done but when you look at
the various breadcrumbs out there and
piece them together
it looks like snyder is exploring the
possibility
that one or more of his limited partners
who own roughly 40 percent of the
franchise
could be behind this effort to recruit
former and current employees to try to
bring him down
whoa it's amazing and and you know look
the reports are out there that these
folks want to sell
and as we discussed at the time well if
you can't sell
you you just you hope that maybe the guy
who owns the majority share
sells and so that this is an aggressive
effort by snyder to go all the way to
the bottom of that rabbit hole and find
out whose fingerprints are
on this and it has the potential to be a
piece of litigation unlike any we've
ever seen where we have
the majority owner of an nfl team
potentially
targeting one or more of his partners
potentially depending upon where the
evidence leads
for an allegation that they were
conspiring with current and former
employees in an effort to bring him down
by essentially
and again this is where the breadcrumbs
potentially lead
the allegation would be that they were
in some way paying these people
to say things that weren't true about
daniel snyder
in order to bring him down if that's
where this goes chris
we've never seen anything like it and we
probably never will again well i've
never heard of anything like it i mean i
understand daniel snyder trying to you
know dig to the bottom of this and
figure this out
you know i i will say this just at the
very base level and again yeah you're
right it's all speculation at this point
we don't know we've heard a million
rumors and stories both of you and i
um i will say that it does seem
you know not so coincidental to me
that we heard rumblings from you know
the minority owners
of the washington football team and then
yeah they might want to sell their
shares and whatever else and then a few
weeks later
that whole you know washington post
story came out
i did find that a little peculiar to go
wait i just heard there's some people
here that don't want to be a part of
this anymore
and now all of a sudden there's a story
about you know the whole thing
falling apart or issues in washington
whatever it may be so
yeah uh i mean fascinating i don't know
i really don't know so you know we'll
yeah we'll see what did like what kind
of answers daniel snyder gets
and he is not letting go of this and we
have seen in the past he had sued
against the washington city paper he he
hit look if he genuinely believes that
there is number one an effort to try to
bring him down
coming from within the house within the
building
and that they are lying about him in an
effort to expedite that process then i
say go for it
go ahead dick right see what you can
find right and and we'll see where the
evidence leads and again
we're not making making any accusations
what we're doing is interpreting
what has been reported based on what's
in the filing
that was submitted to a federal court
yesterday wherever it leads it leads but
it looks like
at this point daniel snyder and his
council are not ruling out
anything including the possibility that
maybe one or more of his limited
partners
could be behind an alleged effort to try
to bring him down
and uh man we're going to continue to
monitor it and we'll talk about it as
need be here
or on pft live or at profootballtalk.com
any of the various platforms
we're going to call it a day chris
thanks as always for your contributions
everybody have a great day we'll see you
back here again on wednesday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports